this season a lot happened and you've
had a lot of you've gone through a lot
classes yes watching back what are you
most proud of is there a scene or a
moment that sticks out where you're just
proud of yourself well I'm proud of my
resolve and I'm proud of my ability to
stand up for myself and to not stop and
to not break and to not
um quit now are there moments of tears
and do I regret mixing alcohol and
antidepressants and those are not good
moments yes however I am human going
through a very tough time in my life and
I did it on television and so I'm not
going to beat myself up over something
that's very human you know it's been
very hard we often the same question and
she said your guys
for you guys how do you feel about
watching well if you remember that when
we started we're friendly and then it
turned into not being friendly so it's
nice to have peace and rebuild it and
that's what I've asked for is time and
understanding and understanding that I'm
rebuilding my life so that is nice and
that was very kind of hard to say being
at bravocon kind of in the middle of the
reunion I'm sure is a little odd but the
most challenging part of the reunion for
you and kind of where you stand with all
about members well I think that last
year's reunion was much harder than this
year's reunion for me
um I'm fine you know I I'm okay I I said
what I had to say and did what I needed
to do and that's it
um certain celebrities like Jennifer
Lawrence Jon Hamm have had some strong
opinions I guess you can say of um some
of your words and actions on the show of
course people watching the show don't
have the full story so what would your
thoughts on that John hem can shake me
and call me honey anytime he wants to do
not threaten me with a good time John
had and as for Jennifer Lawrence Hey
listen you know what I was asked a
question by Andy and I responded
thank you very much